شيعه اهلي بلده عزون شرقه مدينه قلقيليه
جثمان الشهيد الفتى محمد سليم البالغ من
العمر 15 عاما وقتلت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الليله الماضيه الفتى محمد
سليم برصاصه في الظهر خلال مواجهات عنيفا
اندلعت بين شبان فلسطينيين وقوات الاحتلال
لدى اقتحامها المدخل الشرقيه لبلده
اعتقلت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ليله
الماضيه ثمانيه فلسطينيين في ارجاء عده
بالضفه الغربيه وشملت حمله الاعتقالات
مدينه قلقيليه وقريه سلواد شمال رام الله
ومنطقه ام الشرايط بالشرايط بالمدينه
وقريه طمون بالاغوار يواصل جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي عمليات التنشيط الواسعه في
منطقه حواره وجنوب مدينه نابلس لاقتفاء
اثر منفذ عمليه اطلاق نار اسفرت عن مقتل
مستوطنين اثنين قبل عده ايام بينما تستمر
العمليات العسكريه في محيط مدينه اريحا
وذلك لمطارده منافذ اطلاق نار
لمقتل مستوطن الاحد الماضي